[Musique]
ça fait un an
aujourd'hui jour pour jour que le
premier morts officiels chinois du
coronavirus a été recensé un an plus
tard la chine à nouveau coupée du monde
deux de ces villes après une résurgence
des contaminations
il ya cette dangereuse deuxième vague de
la pandémie dans laquelle se trouve
notre pays
comme tant de pays européens des eaux
fils
les prochaines semaines de khyber
constitueront probablement la phase la
plus dure de la pandémie
cet invariant finalement qui change
complètement la donne pour cette rentrée
d'année le site presque une nouvelle
épidémie dans l'épidémie et ce mutant se
répand plus rapidement 50% de plus que
les autres souches du virus et du coup
l'angleterre comme vous le savez
plongeant situations extrêmement
difficiles en ce virus continue de
progresser à raison de 50% en cas de
plus par semaine à la frontière à
londres nous a demandé nos passeports
nos résultats de tests et où on allait
en france pour autant les seuls
contrôles visant le royaume uni ne
suffisent plus car le variant est
aujourd'hui présent dans 22 pays
européens selon l' oms voyez ce que dit
la maire de paris avec de telles
carences le débarquement de juin 1944
aurait échoué
je ne remets pas en question l'ordre de
vaccination établi qu'ils commencent par
les plus fragiles mais je ne comprends
toujours pas le retard à l'allumage et
la responsabilisant les régions
responsables dans les départements
faisant respirer le pays vouloir tout
concentré au sommet c'est risquer la
congestion cérébrale et c'est pour ça
que le système aujourd'hui est lourd
pesant et attentif
je suis assez surpris d'entendre des
leçons de logistique de la part d'une
élue qui n'a pas su gérer le veni qui
n'a pas su gérer
l'autolib qui a montré que s'agissant de
la logistique
elle savait transformer l'or en plomb
alors même qu'il ya plus de
fonctionnaires à la ville de paris qu'à
la commission européenne qu'elle attaque
je réponds à une attaque qui me semble
assez gratuite c'est assez prématuré de
se dire on peut se faire vacciner tout
de suite alors qu'on a que six mois de
recul par rapport au vaccin
j'ai peur par exemple qu'on dise dans
cinq ans à cause du vaccin pour le lac
au vide
vous avez des clarines sclérose en
plaques vous avez déclaré un problème un
problème neurologique musculaire fin
voilà
c'est vraiment tous ces effets
indésirables qu'on ne connaît pas
actuellement qui me font peur je ne suis
pas rassuré par un procédé qui est tout
à fait nouveau dont on ne connaît pas
les conséquences
je préfère les formes traditionnelles de
vaccination et je m'étonne que quand on
est dans une crise d'une ampleur pareil
on avait choisi re précisément ce qu'on
ne savait pas faire jusqu'à présent si
vous voulez faites le moi je suis pour
que ce soit libre mais je vais pouvoir
choisir je ne veux pas être votre
cobayes
après dans cinq ans dans dix ans ce sont
des fantasmes
ce sont des fantasmes parce que les
campagnes précédentes de vaccination ont
donné lieu à ses fantasmes et qu'ils
n'ont jamais été suffisamment démenti le
président trump a cherché à renverser
les résultats d'une élection et d'une
électrique leaf table il a cherché à
faire des tas en trompant les gens avec
des mensonges
le président trump est un dirigeant raté
et où il restera dans l'histoire comme
le pire président de tous les temps ce
qui est bien c'est qu'il sera bientôt
aussi inutile qu'un vieux twitter google
et apple j'ai vérifié encore ce matin
mais en ont retiré de leur magasin
d'applications l'application qu'on
appelle par leur un possible de la
télécharger ce matin par leur c'est quoi
c'est l'équivalent d'un tweeter des pros
trump ses 4 millions d'utilisateurs pour
google et pour apple y circulent en ce
moment des contenus incitant la violence
voire des appels au meurtre
je ne suis pas d'accord pour que les
grandes entreprises comme facebook ou
twitter décide de couper le compte de
monsieur tard vous propose de lui pour
l'instant ça marche mais à 9 heures
c'est fini parce que les serveurs de
l'application parleurs ils sont hébergés
ou chez amazon
un autre géant de la tête qui a décidé
de complètement coupé l'accès aux
données
donc ça veut dire que ce matin par leur
sera complètement inopérant évidemment
là dessous il n'y a aucune décision de
justice
on voit qu'on n'est pas au bout du débat
mais la norme ne peut pas être qu'à
réseau social décide de lui même de
couper tout seul l'oligarchie digital
est une des menaces qui pèsent sur les
états et sur les démocraties la
régulation des géants du digital ne peut
pas et ne doit pas se faire par les gens
du digital elle est nécessaire se faire
par le peuple souverain par les états et
par la justice